thain aurait cette fois ci les résultats
sont bien là après le fiasco
retentissant de l'iowa le deuxième
scrutin afin de désigner le candidat
démocrate pour la présidentielle de
novembre 2020 s'est déroulée sans
encombre le new hampshire petit état du
nord-est américain a confirmé certaines
tendances entrevues il ya neuf jours
dans l'iowa
annoncé favori des sondages bernie
sanders arrive en tête
selon les premières estimations des
médias américains il obtient 27 12 6%
des voix et devant speed beauty djedj
vainqueur surprise dans l'iowa qui
obtient 23 3% des suffrages exprimés et
permettez moi de dire ce soir que cette
victoire est le début de la fin pour
donald trump avec des victoires derrière
nous le vote populaire dans l'iowa et la
victoire ici ce soir nous allons au
nevada nous allons en caroline du sud
nous allons gagner ces états aussi
auteur d'un très bon score avec ses 19
points 5 % la sénatrice modérée
amy klobuchar arrive en troisième
position
longtemps annoncé favori de cette
primaire joe biden subi un cuisant
revers avec moins de 10% des voix
n'arrivant qu'en cinquième position
derrière la sénatrice elizabeth warren
une nouvelle contre-performance qui a
poussé l'ancien vice-président de barack
obama à s'envoler vers la caroline du
sud
prochaine étape des primaires avant même
la publication des résultats
il y a trop de personnes ici à remercier
merci merci à tous je viens juste de
parler à nos compagnons du new hampshire
ils ont fait un bon travail mais je veux
vous dire le peuple du nevada regarde je
tiens à préciser que nous saluons leur
diversité comme état je vais être là bas
pour les voir très bientôt
ce soir cependant nous venons d'entendre
les deux premiers des 50 états deux
d'entre eux
à toute la nation pas la moitié de la
nation pas un quart de la nation pas 10%
de deux maintenant du jeu vient on dit
que c'est le début de quelque chose pas
la fin et le combat pour en finir avec
la présidence trump vient juste de
commencer juste de commencer et tremplin
ou fossoyeur des ambitions des candidats
le du ranch heures à vue le sénateur du
colorado
michael bennet jeter l'épongé tout comme
l'entrepreneur andrew yang
ils ne seront plus que neuf en lice le
29 février pour la troisième étape de la
primaire en caroline du sud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]